frédéric hammel vous êtes stratège de
marché chez orange et o'brian cours
tient aux produits dérivés à la bourse
de chicago 80 % de vos clients sont des
producteurs de l'est du canada
bonsoir monsieur hamel bonsoir monsieur
fignon alors comment va le marché des
grains en général en général le marché
des grains noirs américains quand on
regarde le maïs le soja le blé sont dans
une tendance baissière depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois déjà
donc les prix sont relativement bas par
rapport à l'historique des dernières
années devraient donc combien à peu près
je pense beaucoup au maïs là peut-être
qu'on peut parler du maïs paix parlons
simplement du ps
le prix en amérique du nord évidemment
le prix et négociées à la bourse de
chicago
oui on parle d'un prix en dollars us par
boisseau mais lorsqu on convertit c'est
de donner lors on parle d'un prix qui
autour de 150 145 $ us la tonne métrique
évidemment avec la conversion du taux de
change au québec ça nous ramènerait en
théorie autour de 180 185 par exemple
sauf que le prix local le maïs si
quelqu'un possédait du boum ace au
québec il se vendrait au bas mot 240 sur
les marchés mais alors pourquoi il a
souhaité qu'à parce que c'est un peu le
même principe qu'une personne qui
voudrait de l'eau dans un désert la
disponibilité ou le marchand qui va vous
vendre cette bouteille là c'est très
bien que vous êtes en rupture de stock
dans une certaine mesure dont vous avez
besoin de consommer ce mais cela est le
marché a juste naturellement le prix en
fonction de la porte la portée locale
guy et qu'elle sera donc l'effet des
intempéries de ce dont on vient de
parler de cet hiver hâtif la neige le
vent le froid sur les prix mais c'est
sûr qu'au québec
disons que monsieur legault en parler
préalablement le prix ontario québec
maritime c'est un problème qui est
régionalisé dans une certaine mesure les
prix vont demeurer très fort jusqu'à une
certaine limite où le marché
d'importation
donc le marché où on va être capable
d'aller s'approvisionner soit dans le
nord-est américain ou soit au brésil ou
soit en argentine par exemple et quand
on va réussir à importer sur dans les
ports québécois c'est l'eau il va avoir
une certaine baisse de prix potentiel
mais je ne crois pas que les prix
risquent de baisser parce que la demande
va être très forte au québec puis aussi
en amérique du nord en général pour le
maïs au niveau de la production porcine
bovine et aussi de voler quelles sont
les quantités de production par année en
ce moment au québec on produit grosso
modo une année une bonne année
représente à peu près 3.7 3.8 millions
de tonnes le maire de metz
exactement c'est cette année on est à
combien cette année la récolte devrait
représenter autour de évidemment ça
reste des estimations autour de 3.2 3.4
millions de tonnes le problème comme
comme hôtes et invités précédent le
mentionner c'est le poids de ce gala
c'est à dire chaque grain à une valeur
nutritive beaucoup moindre que par les
années passées
donc ça fait en sorte que pour un animal
pour tirer son énergie pour tirer aussi
la quantité de protéines qu'il a besoin
pour grandir pour grossir va devoir
gérer encore plus de ce mauvais mais
juste bien comprendre pourquoi la valeur
nutritive et moins bonnes parce que la
qualité du produit est affecté
exactement ça exactement donc plus un
maïs et de bonne qualité plus l'animal
en retirent un bénéfice au niveau de sa
croissance
c'est tout l'ensemble du canada on était
à peu près à combien en termes de
tonnage la production de maïs global
canadienne représente 14 millions de
tonnes donc c'est sûr que le québec
représente grosso modo veillée de 5% de
la production canadienne
par contre quand on le met sur une
échelle nord américaine les etats-unis
produisent 347 millions de tonnes
comparativement à trois points qu'à donc
on est rendu à 10 ans pour un exactement
et donc si un problème on peut importer
la exact oui le président impacts de
l'industrie de l'éthanol dans
l'industrie l'industrie d'éthanol au
québec on a une
grandes sociétés qui fabriquent de
l'éthanol à varennes bruit consomme à
peu près 20 % de la récolte québécoise
de maïs dont on parle à peu près 6 1 46
cent cinquante mille tonnes de maïs par
année et si le restant de l'industrie
qui se partagent le reste donc les
éleveurs de porcs de bovins et de
volailles et de zinc est ce que comme
une sorte de réserve annuel de grains de
maïs
oui vous faites bien de mentionner la
réserve constituée à peu près 300 milles
à 400 mille tonnes évidemment cette
année étant donné que la demande de
grains la demande de grains au québec le
pot ils ont qui est consommé par tout
les types d'industries que ce soit
humaine semences industrielle et la
moulée en général représentent à peu
près trois points 4 millions de tonnes
donc c'est sûr que de façon naturelle
offre demande oblige la courbe devrait
c'est au niveau de la demande devrait
baisser ou des produits substituts
devrait compenser pour la perte de maïs
utilisé normalement dans ligne blanche
en terminant est-ce que la menace d'une
grève au canadien national
il ya beaucoup de nouvelles sur le
canadien national depuis la semaine
passée est ce que ça pouvait
est ce que ça pourrait avoir un effet
sur sur le transport de grains sur la
disponibilité du grès c'est certain que
ça peut avoir un effet la beauté c'est
que les grands lacs sont toujours
ouverts présentement donc la voie
maritime devrait être ouverte malgré le
grand froid qu'on a connus devraient
rester ouvertes jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2019 peut-être même début de
melgven on va croiser les doigts pour ça
donc plusieurs plusieurs voudra qui
devrait être en mesure de traverser les
grands lacs bien merci monsieur abel
pour cette analyse ce soir très
intéressant merci bonsoir marois